hey everyone I'm Tiffany Smith for
Fandango movie clips and these are my
top 10 movies to give thanks for in at
number 10 in Scent of a Woman this one
is really just all about the acting
performances for me this is the
birthplace of Al Pacino's famous who won
these two men is not couple really
helping to change each other is just
what Thanksgiving is all about can you
dance a tango and drive a Ferrari better
than anyone I've ever seen in at number
nine we've got Bridget Jones diary fall
is the perfect weather for me for
rom-coms which doesn't happen often but
it's the weather when you can really
curl up with a book and blanket and tea
and watch Bridget Jones fall in and out
of love and into love again I like you a
pop from the smoking just as you are at
number eight its Groundhog Day with a
whole lot of Bill Murray sarcasm zing
miss pilbow from a crotchety man to one
who loves his city
I'm Andy now and could connect with a
super hottie like Andie MacDowell after
learning to be not such a jerk should
help you be nicer to your family unless
you want to relive Thanksgiving over and
over and over again number 7 we have
planes trains and automobiles a John
Hughes classic with some serious heart
and humor and when you put Steve Martin
and John Candy in anything I am on board
especially like that awkward in the bed
sequence what they have together these
are pillows
I mean guys they just want to get home
for Thanksgiving number six is Nightmare
Before Christmas what is the best
stop-motion films from Tim Burton's
crazy creepy and also heartwarming mind
kid Jack saved Christmas in the end
after his team sort of ruins it well
you'll just have to watch to find out
number 5 is about time I think this is
one of the best films that shows a
family who just really loves each other
oh and did I mention that all the guys
in this family can time travel sounds
kind of weird but it really is just a
great love story between a father and
son at number four we have Harry Potter
all of them because what better place to
eat your Thanksgiving meal than in
Hogwarts main hall right so if you want
a marathon of magical proportions that
the whole family will love might I
suggest Terry Puhl top guys if you don't
watch this movie you're gonna get
yourself killed
found at number 3 it's cooked we've got
an all grown-up Peter Pan played by
Robin Williams who has to go back to
Neverland to fight Dustin Hoffman's
version of Captain Hook where my
favorite scenes at the dining table
scene where all the food turns into
super colorful playdough at number 2 is
legends of the fall hello guys fall is
in the title but is an awesome family
love story with beautiful scenery
spoiler alert
his wife dies and it is so upsetting but
if that means he's single
in that world right it's one of my
favorite Brad Pitt films if there's ever
been a question about Brad Pitt just
being a pretty face I think that he
proves in this movie that he is an
incredible actor as well coming in at
number one is the middle-earth saga now
if you know me at all you knew that this
was gonna come in at number one because
there's no bad time to watch the Lord of
the Rings and with the final film from
The Hobbit series coming out the Battle
of the five armies this is the perfect
way to prepare yourselves and I gotta
admit they're kind of like my dream
Thanksgiving family I mean you've got
Frodo and Sam wise and Merry and pip and
Gandalf and Gimli and Legolas and Eragon
and Aon and Aaron and then also you have
to add in Sauron and Saruman because you
can't have the good guys win unless
there are some bad guys for them to
fight right so sit down on your couch
with your second round of Turkey and
watch some good guys place and orcs
I'm on 7g just to recap my top 10 films
to give thanks for our scent of a woman
Bridget Jones diary Groundhog Day planes
trains and automobiles Nightmare Before
Christmas about time Harry Potter hook
legends of the fall and the middle-earth
saga well that's my top 10 but we want
to hear what your favorite Thanksgiving
films are so make sure you leave them in
the comments below
I'm Tiffany Smith for Fandango movie
clips and I'll see you next time
you